of the many stunning performances last
year here are the five nominated for
Best Performance in a leading role
I almost opened the envelope too soon
because I'm so excited
Morgan Freeman in the Shawshank
Redemption Tom Hanks and Forrest Gump
Nigel Hawthorne in the madness of King
George
Paul Newman in nobody's fool
John Travolta in Pulp Fiction
and the Oscar goes to Tom Hanks and
Forrest Gump
thank you I'm standing here in lieu of
my fellow nominees who are just as
deserving if not more so of this moment
I'm standing here because of an army of
people who over the course of a
back-breaking schedule that was set by
Bob Zemeckis who worked much harder than
I did and had much more risk if our
success if our efforts were not
successful I'm empowered to stand here
thanks to the ensemble of actors men and
women who I shared the screen with who
in ways that they will never understand
made me a better actor and I am standing
here because the woman I share my life
with has taught me and demonstrates for
me every day just what love is I
man I feel as though I'm standing on
magic legs in a special-effects process
shock that is too unbelievable to
imagine and far too costly to make a
reality but here is my mark and there is
where I'm supposed to look and believe
me the power and the pleasure and the
emotion of this moment is a constant the
speed of light it will never be
diminished nor will my appreciation and
the meaning between two simple words
that I can only offer you here thank you
god bless you in this room and God bless
you all around the world